heute reden wir über die präposition an
an hat im englischen viele übersetzungen
zum beispiel add on up on by oder erbaut
hier sind ein paar beispiele ich stehe
an der haltestelle ich stehe an der
ampel
das poster hängt an der säule
das war link an der scheibe was machst
du am montag
ich steh an deiner seite
an was denkst du
er hat ein haus am meer
es hat geklingelt gehst du mal an die
tür
die präposition ankam man mit dativ und
akkusativ benutzen dativ benutzt man
dann wenn man worte beschreibt und
akkusativ benutzt man wenn man
bewegungen zu orten beschreibt dativ ich
stehe an der tür akkusativ ich gehe an
die tür
hallo datis
ich stehe am fenster akkusativ ich gehe
an das fenster wenn man an mit dem
kombiniert sagt man an
ich stehe am pferd ja wir sehen uns am
montag
und hier noch ein paar beispiele die
gitarren hängen an der wand
ich hänge noch eine gitarre an die wand
die magnete hängen an dem ganz schrank
die pfanne hängt am haken
woran denkst du ich denke dann nichts
was machst du eigentlich am dienstag
am dienstag habe ich frei